nos piden reflejar esta recta a través
de la recta y es igual a menos 4 esta
recta de aquí y nos da entonces estas
herramientas trasladar rotar reflejar o
hacer una potencia o deshacer lo que
estamos a punto de hacer así que bueno
para reflejar esta recta alrededor oa
través de la recta de igual a menos 4
vamos a activar la opción de reflejar y
vamos a mover esta recta a la recta de
igual a menos 4
la recta igual a menos 4 sería esta
recta de aquí todas las coordenadas
sobre esa recta están en menos 4 y vamos
a hacer la reflexión
y ahí tenemos el resultado ahora nos
preguntan cuando una recta reflejada la
imagen creada es una línea
claro si refleja una línea recta obtengo
otra línea recta sabemos que esto es
cierto porque la imagen reflejada tiene
cero puntos extremos estos solo son dos
puntos en la recta para una recta en
realidad no tiene puntos extremos así
que la imagen tampoco va a tener puntos
extremos